hi my name is peridot from kasi I'm a
kernel developer at Wolfram research in
the numerix group today I'll be talking
about finite element methods in and as
it used and as it is used in in dissolve
I will be going over various examples
and we'll be talking about error
analysis as it pertains to finite
element methods thank you
so let's get started on this on finite
element methods so for those who are new
to and dissolve and these always one of
those super functions in Mathematica
that allows you to solve differential
equations large variety of differential
equations start you know it could be
boundary value ordinary differential
equations di ease what have you and I'm
gonna focus on these partial
differential equations and how finite
element methods are used to solve PDE s
now I want to point out for those who
are interested in finite element methods
is that there's a lot of documentation
in Mathematica but because the
documentation is so vast sometimes you
might not be able to find the right page
so we have basically put together all
the links to to the to the relevant
documentation so once you have the
notebook just go ahead and click through
them and it'll take you through the
various math associated with finite
element methods how to use it in and
it's all different methods were happier
so okay so how do you use finite element
methods in any solve well just as you
would solve any partial differential
equation you need three things you need
a governing equation which is the first
one here you need the domain in which
you're going to solve the problem that's
the second one and you need a set of
boundary conditions which is the third
one and once you have formulated these
three things you just present that two
nd solve in the form that is similar to
how you would give it to any give any
differential equation you give it the
equations and the boundary conditions
you give it the dependent variable for
which you want the solution and you say
that the independent variable belongs to
this domain and you go ahead and run
that yeah sure and you get back an
interpolating function which is no
different than what you would get from
any other solution it's got all the
information embedded in it and you can
go ahead and use that interpolating
function to plot do any kind of analysis
and it just works seamlessly so the
finite element part of it is really not
explicitly visible it happens very
seamlessly behind the scenes and just
takes care
of everything for you so what kind of
problems can finite element methods
solve well right now I think I should
just make this a little bigger okay
right now it can solve only this one
problem it's our system of these
problems and this is a linear a very
general linear system of equations and
depending upon what kind of coefficients
these DC alpha gamma beta depending upon
how they're set up or which ones are
eliminated you end up with different
family of equations you could have a
Laplace bas or I could have held you
know wave equations and what have you so
so these are the kind of problems that
we'll be talking about now the there is
currently work underway that will allow
non-linearity to to be handled by Fe M
that's not in right now but that's
that's something we're working on and it
should be in very soon okay so the
second thing that I want to talk or
rather the main thing I want talk about
today is are the boundary conditions and
how you're supposed to apply boundary
conditions to finite element methods in
order to solve the problem correctly
because without that you're sort of you
just shooting in the dark
if you don't understand how boundary
conditions are implemented in finite
element methods so there are there are
two types of boundary conditions that
you can apply one is the direct
condition and the second is the gnomon
condition now the dershlit condition
applies to these red nodal points on the
boundary and the normal values are
applied on the the line segments that
represent the boundary okay so I'm going
to now talk a lot about boundary
conditions and the common gotchas and
what you should be looking out for when
you are dealing with specifying boundary
conditions I'll start with the dershlit
condition the dashlet condition is
defined in this way this is how you
would present it to 2 nd solve the it's
got two arguments the first one tells
you you know what is the numerical value
you want to put at the nodal location
the boundary for at whatever location
and the predicate tells you which nodal
values you should be applying that value
to so for example in this case which we
are going to look at which is the disc
example the boundary says that I want to
put u equal to 0 for X greater than or
equal to 0 so any boundary node that
lies on the right of the the plane is
going to take on a value of u equal to 0
so how do you set it up you said pretty
much like I showed you before you give
the equation the domain and the boundary
condition and we specify that and you
solve and visualize really that's pretty
much it you can see that on the right
hand side this is where the U equal to 0
has been applied and then on the left
hand side which is it's basically left
free it picks up this whatever value it
picks up from solving the system ok so
let's make things a little bit
complicated and we'll progressively make
it more complicated let's start talking
about multiple materials so these are
these are cases wherein you have two
separate materials with different
material properties that are connected
to each other and they share a common
interface with each other in that case
let's if you want to solve a Poisson
equation what happens then so because
there are two separate materials they
have different material properties so
the one material which is in a it's it's
the set up is basically a disc a solid
disc within a disc and and and and they
have different thermal conductivity okay
one one has got one and another one is
ten times more but they are given the
same boundary condition you know X
greater than or equal to zero so the way
you set that up is by putting in this
conditional statement saying that if if
it is less than or equal to one 1/4 then
use this diffusion matrix and if it is
greater then use this one okay and then
you just set up the problem in in this
fashion and when we run it you see that
this is the result you get
so it's slightly different from there
from the first case but if you if you
rotate it you see that at X equal to
four
one-fourth at that inner disk you end up
getting this jump so what is a Fe I'm
doing what is it doing internally so if
you look at the solution let's see you
form element mesh look at the wireframe
type okay then you see this element mesh
you see that internal bound there's a an
internal boundary has been applied okay
and that internal boundary represents
that interface between those two
materials and so it picks up that
internal boundary from the governing
equations puts that in here in there so
that the interface is properly resolved
okay so so that kind of parsing happens
inside of inside of nd solve and
specifically within the FE M framework
so now that I've brought up the topic of
of internal boundaries let me take you
to through one specific example wherein
the user now gives a specification on
the internal boundary itself so I'm
going to again it's going to be a
Poisson problem on a disk but now the
boundary condition changes the derelict
condition says that it's going to be
zero at the outer wall and also at X
square plus y square equal to 1 over 4
and I'm going to set it up in a very
specific way I'm going to use two
element mesh here and I set it up as an
implicit region and I provide the
dershlit condition okay really nothing
more complicated than that and you get a
result and you can see that now because
of the internal boundary that is
specified it forces it back to zero and
then goes back and get started ok notice
a couple of things if you play close
attention there are two things going on
here X greater than or equal to zero you
apply this for the outer case it takes
on you
that huh so the external disk gets that
X equal to zero value only in on one
half of its boundary but the X square
plus y square equal to one-fourth that
gets applied everywhere okay
so that needs so that's one thing you
need to take into account but if it is
very easy to become trapped in in in
some of the subtleties here
especially when you set up your own
domain you know it's got all these bells
and whistles with its internal
boundaries and then you go go to solve a
particular problem you might expect some
behavior that you weren't expecting so
for example what would you expect to
happen if I were to change the problem
and have this dershlit condition be
applied to only X greater than or equal
to zero and remove this condition while
still holding on to this still this
domain that I've created now you would
expect that you know you'd go back to
the original problem but when you run
the system you get this is this bug no
it's not it's actually to be expected
this is how this is what a finite
element does what it does is internally
it recognizes that you have you
explicitly told in the domain that there
is an internal boundary I'm going to
treat that as an internal boundary and
therefore that irrational condition is
going to get applied to that as well all
right so so you need to be aware of how
what finite element is doing internally
and how it's doing the talking so that
so that you can get the right results
okay so that's Dursley conditions now
I'm going to talk about normal
conditions this is a little bit more
complicated than then Dursley conditions
so bear with me when I go through the
math but once I take you through the
matter hopefully why we have chosen this
form and why the gnomon conditions are
defined the way they are will hopefully
become clear so I need to take you first
through the FIM derivation so the way
technically fvm derivation is done is
you have your governing equation you
multiply that with the test function
that test function in this case is
the term fee here you integrate it over
the entire domain and during the process
of integration you do this integration
by parts and you end up with a server
valium integral which is the first term
here and a surface integral okay and the
surface integral has a form that is that
basically comes from the governing
equation and so what internally finite
element does is it it treats this red
part as the left hand side of the gnomon
condition and it replaces it with the
right hand side which is the G - qu so
technically it's your normal condition
that you're looking at is this Grier
this red term equal to this blue term
but what you're giving to NDA solve and
to Fe M is the right hand side this left
hand side is assumed that you already
have it in the right form okay so that's
kind of the gotcha here so which means
that this G and Q term that you have to
put in have to properly account for how
this left hand side which is implicitly
embedded inside of an of Fe M so you
know so you have to account so that so
that the coefficients and everything
match up properly okay so time to
confuse everybody all right let's take
this simple 1d example I'm going to
apply it's a boundary value problem but
we'll solve it using finite elements on
the left left boundary I'm going to give
it a dershlit condition right side I'm
going to give it a normal condition
so if I give it to dissolve it gives me
back and an exact solution so it's good
we can compare it with our numerical
system the domain is just a line going
from 1 to 2 and now I'm going to give
the boundary condition simply just in in
its original form but when I give it in
this form internally finite element
looks sees this the first thing here in
the red and therefore the red
now becomes part of the Noi Minh
condition okay so this red term gets
copied down here and you have your g- qu
here okay so which means that this is
what finite element method is seeing and
so in order for you to get or satisfy
this Norman boundary condition of your
original problem you need to match the
coefficients so just a little back of
the envelope calculation will tell you
that G has to be 15 by 4 and Q has to be
3 by 4 okay
so it's that's where the subtlety of
norman value lies okay and so then when
you plug those numbers in you get back a
solution I mean the it's it's within the
tolerance of what Fe M is producing it's
it's not the most accurate but it is it
is consistent okay so if you are still
with me I want to take you through one
more example that'll read at will
that'll show you the flexibility of
finite of Neyman value and the and the
Fe M framework and how you can specify
the problems so I'm going going to take
the same example but I'm going to write
it differently what I'm gonna do it is
I'm gonna write the system in what is
called as a conservative form meaning
that the I'll take this u u double prime
and I'll take the first derivative out
so it'll be d DX in the bracket it'll be
three u prime of X plus fifteen you okay
so the first the this first two terms in
this governing equation will get will
get grouped together in what is called
as a conservative form and that's what
you're going to give to Andi solve by
applying this inactive term to it okay
so there's your divergence of your
gradient okay and when you give it in
this form to 2 2 nd solve what it sees
is this term here in the in the in that
in the in the divergence term okay which
is different from the from the previous
example now you have this 15 you coming
here which means now again you have to
do your calculations back of the
envelope calculations to figure out what
Q&U is because you gave
your differential equation in this form
so in this case you end up with your G
becoming still having the same value but
Q ends up having an additional quantity
of 15 attached to it okay and so you get
the exact same solution okay so there is
significant flexibility inside of the FM
framework that you can manipulate these
equations in any shape or form but when
you're dealing with moment conditions
it's kind of important to know what form
you gave it so that you can apply the
right boundary conditions okay so this
is one of those another example where in
the mesh in this case comes from maybe
some external source and you don't have
much control over you know the symbolic
thing associated with it but what this
boundary mesh does have are what are
called as these element markers and so
you can apply use that information of
element markers to specify the neumann
conditions or the dershlit conditions at
those marker locations so in this case I
don't know whether you can see it there
is red embedded in between here okay
so that's one set of area where and you
want to apply boundary conditions and
the black is another place you want to
apply so you solve the norman common
problem here it takes a few seconds it's
it's a rather large problem but there
are you that's the solution you have
okay and the reason you want to do with
that rather than specifying the boundary
conditions is because you just don't
have that information but you do have
element marker information and that
that's quite used that's quite useful
and a lot of people use it that way now
the thing I want to bring focus to is
that we are doing this thing that really
doesn't conform with the syntax of the
display condition in the dershlit
condition we gave it the differential
equation and then we gave it the
dershlit condition which are the
boundary conditions and so on but with
the lot with the normal condition we're
actually putting it as
as an equality sign and attaching it to
the differential equation itself so
maybe if I if I were to go back you see
what we're doing here this is the
differential equation and then we are
equal to this nomin value so why is it
that we're doing where we have chosen to
do it in this fashion and and and the
answer to that is that take a case where
in your maybe this wasn't well this will
work you have a case where in this G
takes on a value but Q is zero and when
you have that Q equal to zero then you
don't have a dependent variable existing
inside of normal value so if you have a
system of PDEs which one of these P DS
contain that my Mon condition you should
have you need to apply it to the
appropriate PDE and that's the reason
that the normal condition is directly
embedded inside the differential
equation okay so that's that's again one
of those syntax that that FIM users and
mathematical need to be aware of all
right so enough of nomen value and the
boundary conditions I want to talk
quickly about error analysis I'm going
to show you a couple of examples and
you'll see immediately that the results
seem completely weird it's the same
thing it's a disk the second one is an
implicit region which defines a disk I
tell it to use and integrate if you if
you do integration on that you get pi so
we have something to compare it to but
depending upon how we specify the region
we are getting radically different
results you're getting really good
results if we give it a symbolic case
terrible results are forgiving
discretize region and almost terrible
results if you use two element mesh so
why is that well in the first case the
symbolic region allows you to have
complete control of the region that you
are discretizing and allowing how the
elements to be placed with discretize
region what's happening is that the
boundaries are are you know they're
curved boundaries but after it after
discretization they're just linear
elements they're just lines and so you
lose a lot of accuracy when you
the boundaries in that fashion because
that that curve is not accounted for two
element mesh on the other hand does
account for that curve but the
resolution or the number of points it
uses maybe a little less which is why
you see a little less accuracy so you
need to be aware of how you present your
region to to to to whatever numerical
system that you're solving so what
happens is this is the disk but when you
discretize it you just discretizing the
line so you end up with a polygon and
and and all that error is this area that
you're losing right but if you use two
element mesh you are using second order
elements so using curves and that
improves the accuracy significantly okay
well what does that mean for us when
we're solving PDEs well one of the
things any numerical analysts should do
is to do things like error checking grid
convergence all that finite element
methods if you're using linear elements
you should get second-order accuracy
right I'm not going to run through this
I'll just show you when I present case
one which is I'm just solving a Poisson
equation but now but I'm giving it a
discretized region you know so the
boundaries are only lines so because
it's only first order accurate you get
the solution when you compare it to the
exact solution turns out to be H square
but when you give it a symbolic region
everything is very well resolved and you
get a fourth order accuracy okay and
that's where you that's what you need to
pay attention to you know try as best as
possible to give it symbolic region or
if not at least make sure that the
boundaries are properly resolved now you
need to be aware that sometimes a
discretized region can represent the
boundary exactly for example if you have
a rectangle then linear elements
represent you know those lines represent
your boundary exactly in that case even
if you were to give it a symbolic region
or a discretized region you'll always
get a fourth order accurate result as
you decrease the result so
Proteas that that that that you need to
take into account one final thing is an
error analysis is residual checking you
take a problem solve it with finite
element methods use and then you ask
yourself well how well is it
representing if I put the solution back
into my differential equation how well
is the solution behaving well when you
that's the solution you plug that
solution back into the differential
equation and the result looks absolutely
horrendous does that mean that the
solution is wrong absolutely not if you
look on the right graph that's the
solution with the exact solution and
that's pretty decent but on the
left-hand side you have a residue and
the residual is not coming out correctly
because in when you're doing finite
element analysis you the highest order
derivative goes down by one so that
highest order derivative information
does not ends up having a really bad
approximation in the interpolating
function okay and so this kind of
residual checking when you if you if you
do that make sure to keep these things
in mind okay
and I think that's pretty much what I
wanted to cover I think we have we have
time for talk for a few questions I hope
you found this information useful and
finally from a message from Oliver from
from Asia there you go thank you I'll
take any questions you have yes sir
arbitrary domains for yeah sure go for
it
yeah it will work on any domain you can
define well if it's complicated enough
you'd most of the time you'd end up
defining it using implicit region you
know with various combination of
predicates you can also import your own
file which contains the mesh it'll just
work no no no problems at all this was
just an example because I wanted to keep
things simple I know what you're saying
my my first intuition is yes it should
but I see I can easily see problems
arising especially if that if the if the
coefficient term all of a sudden drops
out maybe you can you can set up the
system so that the term suddenly drops
out I wonder what happens then I haven't
tested that but but yeah it should be
theoretically the the framework should
should handle that yeah other questions
to account for the continuity condition
between the interfaces the if the
interface is known a priority it it will
pick it up yes and and and it I the way
I understand it is that it will it will
it will do the it will set up the
elements in the in the proper way so
that the integration is done in that
consistent order so that you don't get
this wild oscillations right at the
interface yeah okay one please yeah GN
that yeah yeah if you yes that it
variant like the sample T associate
generally the the Neyman values in
typical PDS aren't that with that
condition that I put in there for the
OTS as a robin condition you know it's
got the derivative and the value
associated with it and that's a
synthetic problem I put together to
emphasize it but in most cases it's just
the normal derivative is equal to zero
in which case you do really don't have
to worry it just set that equal to zero
you're good to go
yeah but but if you are dealing with
these complicated Robin kind of
conditions yes please do a little bit of
calculation yeah yes
they're actually derivatives of the
response okay structural mechanics and
crack yeah okay the derivative data or
or the at the Gauss points geez yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah trick right I
yeah yeah absolutely well any other
questions
cool let's get to lunch thank you